encuentra la integral indefinida general
integral de 2x de x cual de las gráficas
muestra abajo más bien cuál de las
gráficas abajo muestra varios miembros
de la familia así es que si calculamos
la integral de 2x de x
necesitamos encontrar la anti derivada
de 2x la cual es igual a 22 que
multiplica a x cuadrada si aquí el
exponente del x es 1 sumamos un al
exponente y tenemos x cuadrada sobre
tenemos que dividir esto entre el nuevo
exponente entre 2 y esto es igual a x
cuadrada y esto lo podrías haber hecho
directamente si sabes que la derivada de
x cuadrada es 2x entonces la anti
derivada de 2x es x cuadrada pero aún no
hemos terminado pues recuerda esta no es
la única anti derivada de esto si
agregamos cualquier constante aquí si
sumamos cualquier constante y calculamos
la derivada de esto también es igual a
2x porque cuando estás derivando una
constante con respecto a x
la constante no cambia así es que su
derivada es cero así es que el anti
derivada aquí podemos decir que toma
esta forma la forma de x cuadrada más c
y eso qué significa visualmente si aquí
tenemos el eje lleno lo voy a hacer
mejor lo puedo hacer mejor que esto sí
aquí tenemos el eje y eso está mejor si
este es el eje y
y este de aquí
es el eje x como se ve igual a x
cuadrada cuál es la gráfica de yegua la
equis cuadrada y lo que voy a hacer es
más bien un boceto de cómo se ve la
gráfica de ye igual a x cuadrada ahí la
tenemos qué pasa entonces se agrega una
constante digamos se agregó la constante
2 2 es una constante válida entonces
sería igual a x cuadrada más 2 déjame
escribir esto aquí esta de aquí la
gráfica de ye igual a x cuadrada
podríamos decir que aquí la constante es
cero así es que es igual a x cuadrada
más 0 qué pasa entonces si se tiene un
valor positivo por ejemplo cuál es la
gráfica de ye igual a x cuadrada más no
sé más digamos 5 la intersección de la
gráfica con el eje i es igual a 5
básicamente vamos a trasladar la gráfica
hacia arriba se unidades que en este
caso es 5 así es que trasladamos la
gráfica 5 unidades hacia arriba y
obtenemos algo que se ve como esto
simplemente hemos trasladado la grava
original hacia arriba y aquí ya podrías
estar considerando que quizás esta es la
opción adecuada pero esta opción también
nos muestra casos donde la intersección
con el eje i es negativa a partir de que
hemos sumado una constante pero observa
que esta constante puede también ser un
número negativo a 15 de 5 a 15 es 0 pero
también se puede ser negativo se también
puede ser menos 5 si queremos graficar
igual a x cuadrada + menos 5 que en
realidad es igual a x cuadrada menos 5
entonces la gráfica se va a ver como
esto estamos trasladando la gráfica de
ye igual a x cuadrada 5 unidades hacia
abajo aquí trasladamos 5 unidades hacia
arriba y aquí trasladamos 5 unidades
hacia abajo así es que la gráfica se
trasladase unidades si se es positiva es
hacia arriba y si se es negativa es
hacia abajo
así es que definitivamente b es la
gráfica donde se muestran la familia de
soluciones al calcular la derivada de
cualquiera de las funciones que están
representadas por estas gráficas se
obtiene 2x otra manera de verlo es que
la anti derivada
la integral indefinida de 2x de x es
igual a x cuadrada
lo cual se puede representar por
gráficas que se ven como esto
básicamente la traslación de la gráfica
de igual a x cuadrada hacia arriba o
hacia abajo y aquí se podían agregar
tantas gráficas como se quisiera